♪♪
Narrator: THOUSANDS OF YEARS
AGO, OUR EARLIEST ANCESTORS
MIGHT HAVE PICKED UP
A POINTED ROCK
AND SPUN IT BETWEEN THEIR HANDS
TO BORE A HOLE
IN SOMETHING
THEY WANTED TO MODIFY.
TODAY, YOU CAN BUY DRILL BITS
IN ALL SHAPES AND SIZES.
DRILL BITS ARE OFTEN ASSOCIATED
WITH CARPENTRY,
BUT FROM ELECTRONICS
TO SURGERY TOOLING,
THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF FIELDS
THAT REQUIRE ULTRA-THIN,
HIGH-PERFORMANCE DRILL BITS.
THE PRODUCTION PROCESS BEGINS
WITH LENGTHS
OF 100% CARBIDE
CALLED BLANKS.
♪♪
A DIAMOND GRINDING WHEEL
LUBRICATED WITH A SPECIALIZED
CUTTING LIQUID
IS APPLIED TO A CHAMFERED EDGE
ON ONE TIP OF THE BLANK.
THIS STEP REMOVES
THE ROUGH EDGES LEFT
WHEN THE BLANKS
WERE CUT DOWN TO SIZE.
♪♪
A VIBRATING DEVICE ORGANIZES THE
BLANKS INSIDE A ROTATING BOWL.
THE VIBRATING ACTION SHIFTS
THE BLANKS INTO SINGLE FILE
SO THEY CAN PROCEED
ONE-BY-ONE TO THE NEXT STEP.
THIS MACHINE IS CALLED
A CENTERLESS GRINDER.
THE BLANKS MOVE BETWEEN
TWO ROTATING DRUMS,
WHICH GRINDS THEM DOWN
TO A SPECIFIED LENGTH.
♪♪
THE BLANKS POUR OUT
OF THE MACHINE
IMMERSED IN THE
LUBRICATING FLUID.
AN OPERATOR SELECTS ONE
AND PLACES IT
IN A QUALITY CONTROL GAUGE
TO CHECK
THAT IT MEETS THE MANUFACTURER'S
REQUIRED TOLERANCES.
♪♪
THE BLANKS NOW ENTER
A CNC ROLLOMATIC.
AN OPERATOR SETS UP THE TOOL
AND PROGRAMS ITS WORK PROCESS.
A ROBOTIC AUTO-FEEDER PICKS UP
THE BLANKS ONE-BY-ONE
FROM A SPECIALIZED PALETTE.
THE ROBOTIC ARMS PLACES
EACH BLANK CAREFULLY
AND PRECISELY
IN A WAITING CHUCK, OR COLLAR,
AND THEN MOVES THEM
BACK INTO POSITION.
THE TOOL MOVES FORWARD, HOLDING
THE BLANK PERFECTLY STILL
AS A PAIR OF WHEELS CLOSE IN.
LIQUID COOLANT POURS
OVER THE BLANK
AS THE WHEELS PRECISION
PINCH-GRIND
THE TIP OF THE BLANK,
GRINDING IT DOWN TO ABOUT
1/10 OF A MILLIMETER --
THE WIDTH OF A HUMAN HAIR.
IT'S A DELICATE PROCESS.
THE ROLLOMATIC PRODUCES
48 PIECES PER HOUR.
NEXT, A TECHNICIAN PLACES SMALL
SHEETS OF PLASTIC FOIL IN A JIG.
THE FOIL IS SHIM STOCK,
COLOR-CODED
ACCORDING TO ITS THICKNESS.
THE JIG RAISES THE METAL SUPPORT
TO A SPECIFIED HEIGHT.
WHEN THE BLANK ADVANCES
OVER THE SUPPORT,
A MARK LEFT IN THE BLUE
INK DETERMINES
WHETHER THE METAL BLANK
IS CENTERED.
ONCE COMPLETE, A TECHNICIAN USES
A MAGNIFYING TOOL
TO FINE-TUNE
THE PLACEMENT OF THE BLANK
AND ENSURE THAT
IT'S PERFECTLY CENTERED.
THIS PROCESS CAN TAKE FOUR
TO FIVE HOURS.
THE BLANK IS FINALLY READY FOR
THE CRUCIAL FLUTING PROCESS
THAT WILL TRANSFORM IT FROM
A CYLINDRICAL LENGTH OF CARBIDE
WITH A NARROW TIP
INTO A MICRO DRILL BIT.
AFTER HOURS OF PREPARATION,
THIS OPERATION TAKES
JUST A FEW SECONDS.
AN INDUSTRIAL GRINDING
DIAMOND WHEEL
HAS SLICED A MICROSCOPIC GROOVE
AT A PRECISE ANGLE.
THE TECHNICIAN INSERTS THE BIT,
SHARP-END FIRST,
INTO A PRECISION
MACHINING DEVICE.
A STEEL BUSHING
WITH A BRASS INSERT
HOLDS THE TIP OF THE BIT
IN PLACE
AS A CUTTING WHEEL SLICES
AN ANGLED POINT.
♪♪
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO SEE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A BIT BEFORE
AND AFTER FLUTING.
USING A MAGNIFYING DEVICE,
THE TECHNICIAN CONDUCTS
A QUALITY CONTROL
CHECK OF THE BIT.
AS THE SCREEN REVEALS
THE FINELY-CUT FLUTE,
THE TECHNICIAN ENSURES
THE TOOL'S PARAMETERS MEET
MANUFACTURING STANDARDS.
ONCE SUCH PARAMETER HAS TO DO
WITH THE SHAPE OF THE FLUTE,
WHICH HAS A FORWARD TAPER.
THIS MEANS THE FLUE GROOVE
BECOMES SHALLOWER
FROM TIP TO BASE AT
A VERY PRECISE ANGLE.
THIS FEATURE SIMULTANEOUSLY
STRENGTHENS THE TOOL
WHILE INCREASING THE CHIP FLOW
ALONG THE GROOVE.
ALTHOUGH CARBIDE
IS INCREDIBLY STRONG,
WHEN IT'S MILLED TO
THE THICKNESS OF A HUMAN HAIR,
IT BECOMES FRAGILE.
NEEDLESS TO SAY,
CAREFUL PACKAGING
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.